yesterday you may have heard about this
fast food chains chick-fil-a and Popeyes
got into an argument on Twitter about
who had the better chicken sandwich yes
this is what Twitter's for chick-fil-a
tweeted this bun plus chicken plus
pickles equals love and then Popeyes
responded with y'all good yeah kind of
snarky anyway from that point on it was
all-out war and all that Twitter was
debating was who had the better chicken
sandwich
chick-fil-a or Popeye as well I thought
this would be the perfect opportunity to
bring back a friend of the show to
decide once and for all who has the
better chicken sandwich that's right
it's time once again for Dudley the
taste test dog
[Applause]
all right here's how it works we have a
chick-fil-a sandwich and we have a
Popeyes sandwich now it's time to bring
out Dudley give him a hand ladies and
gentlemen
now
Dudley is an expert take it easy cuddley
Dudley is an expert food taster right
gladly this guy is a connoisseur of all
really good food love the job loves his
job very eager to get to work I think
he's ready and Dudley you decide begin
the taste test go
[Applause]
also eating chick-fil-a okay he pretty
much ate both sandwiches simultaneously
it's a time ladies and gentlemen
no Dudley if you turn around there won't
magically be another sandwich let's see
how this compares to Dudley's pass taste
test results Andy thanks Conan as you
can see here
chick-fil-a versus Popeyes was a time
McDonald's versus Burger King was a time
Taco Bell versus del Taco also a tie
filet mignon versus Arby's a time
Lobster Thermidor versus a dirty sock
that's a tie as well and lastly cat food
versus cat poop a tie
[Applause]